I started taking Fenmen for parasites. I was taking the 10 pound version, one pack per day, for four days, then three days off, and repeat.
This time, I bought the 40 pound version. I'm not sure how I should dose myself now. I weigh 98 from pounds.
I'm also on Ivermectin paste, and I'm getting it over my head.
Okay, so if you're so personally, I wouldn't take Fenmen for parasites. Why not? So they take parasitic medication.
Yeah, you're right. It is. I would take, I would take an herbal antiparasite. If I had, if I was thinking I had parasites, I would take an herbal antiparasitic.
The favorite is the one that we privately able to pair a clear. It's, it's, it's fresh and health products, proverma fugents. It's always been my favorite antiparasitic nutrient, or since I discovered it.
So it's got just a great mix of it and we used it, you know, dozens and dozens and dozens of times for people with parasites.
I wouldn't use the medication for parasites. It has too many side effects at the dosage that you would have to take.
So personally, I just, I wouldn't do that. So I would never recommend that. And then secondly, from a legal medical legal standpoint, I can't tell you to take a medication for parasites.
I just personally wouldn't do that. I would choose something else.
And, you know, make sure that you've discovered, you know, what it is you're trying to deal with. The reason why I like ParaClear is it covers pinworms, tapeworms, roundworms.
It's got the negative about taking ParaClear is that you have to kind of titrate up on the dose. Maybe start a three a day. I've had people have to go up to 12, 15 a day. But for a very short period of time.
So that's something you need to take all the time. And usually you're going to go, you're going to keep a bottle in your cupboard. That's what I do. We have a model of it actually two models. I noticed in our cabinet.
And well, even if I'm feeling down if I feel like I'm coming down with something, I'll take that. So it can be beneficial for viruses and bacteria as well.
But it's really for intestinal liver, parasites, flukes.
And it really does work well. It works. I've used it on people for even trigonosis that has gone to their head to their brain. And it is cleared it up like super fast. So it's my favorite tip. I wouldn't use the medication. I would use ParaClear.
The negative is, okay, if you're 90, fairly 98 pounds, you'll probably take a maximum of six or nine a day, but you might only take that for a couple days or a week. And then you'll titrate back down to three a day and then you might go off of it.
But I only take it for two weeks and just hit it like that for two weeks and then wait a month or so and do it again if you feel like you still have parasites. That's what I'm doing.